Right.
Hello Dr. I am a 23 year old male with
paranoid schizophrenia.
However,
I feel like controlling 95 percent of
it.
Okay,
so let's say I think you mean that
you're controlling 95 percent of it.
I desire to seek a partner,
but I am afraid how to reveal it.
Any advice on how to approach it?
Oh God.
Steven,
that's a really hard question.
Well,
look,
you're not under any obligation when you
first meet someone to drown them in
information about your identity.
So I would say
the devil's in the details.
Fundamentally,
if you have a relationship with someone
and it's progressing and you're being
honest,
my suspicions are that it will come up
with its own accord.
You know,
that you'll be able to tell in the
situation when the right way to
introduce it is,
um,
you know,
if,
if you're asking me this because you've
been in a relationship for a long time
and you haven't revealed it,
then I don't know what to tell you about
that because an [inaudible] I wouldn't
give someone general advice about that.
You know,
if,
uh,
sorry
if I,
if are we speaking to a client and I had
some real
detailed information about their current
situation,
I would sit down and help them
strategize about that.
Ask about the person you're telling.
Figure out how long you've gone out with
them,
figure out a way that it might be
revealed that you would be comfortable
with.
I suspect probably what you should do is
find someone you trust to talk about it.
If you're already in a relationship,
and if you're not,
then assume that if going into the
relationship,
your basic goal is honesty.
That you'll handle it appropriately.
When the situation comes up.